Now that you have seen what data dependencies
look like, let's do a data dependencies quiz
to see if you can find data dependencies
in the program. Let's say that these are
four instructions in our program. Instruction one multiplies
R2 and R3, puts the result in R1.
Instruction two takes R4 and R1, adds them
up, and puts the result in R4. Instruction three
multiplies R5 and R6, puts the result in R1. And the subtract here, instruction
four, subtracts R1 from R4 and puts the result back in R4. You need to indicate
whether there are any dependencies between instruction
I1 and I2. For each of these three
types of dependencies, is there such a dependence?
You need to do that also for I1
to I3, I1 to I4. So is there a dependence from I1 to I4?
And from I2 to I3. To help you out, I'm going to tell you that there is a
read after write dependence here. That there is
no write after read dependence from I1 to
I2. And that there is no write after
write dependence. I'm also going to tell you that
there is no read after write dependence here. But
you need to figure out the remaining eight dependencies.
Put a check mark in each of these boxes
if there is such a dependence between these instructions.